so you've heard a lot about Java
development and now you want to build a
career in the field well you come to the
right place but first things first what
is Java all about Java is a class-based
object-oriented programming language
developed by James Gosling in 1995 and
is the most widely used programming
language in the world
it is literally used in all spheres of
software development be it web or mobile
applications enterprise applications web
servers or embedded systems you'll
definitely encounter code written in
this powerful language and to the no
one's surprise
the demand for Java developers has never
been higher globally there are expected
to be more than 10 million Java
developers in the world and their
average salary a whopping 102 thousand
dollars a year so are you ready to
become a job ready Java developer in six
weeks with simply learns comprehensive
Java training you can in this course
you'll learn and master the basic and
advanced concepts of core Java and a
Java EE get acquainted with frameworks
like hibernate and spring and understand
service-oriented architecture and web
services the training comes with 48
hours of live instructor-led online
training along with real-life industry
project experience quizzes assignments
and more so what are you waiting for
take the first step toward your Java
development career and enroll now all
the best